we're going to start tonight with Carrie
Lake she's running for governor in
Arizona she joins us tonight thank you
so much for coming on so it's very hard
to know if you're not there what is
happening what is your best assessment
of it
ah well I mean it we've got messed up
elections for starters and they've
counted a lot of ballots but they're
still about a half a million left to be
counted and and these are primarily
hardcore Republican voters people who
showed up and brought their ballot in on
Election Day we're starting to get a few
of today's numbers trickling in and
we're getting from some of these drops
74 of the vote 72 percent of the vote
these are heavy duty Republican voters
and and isn't it convenient that they
are the last ballots to be counted they
count all the Democrat votes early and
the Really reliable Republican ballots
are the last to be counted so we're less
than a point away from our opponent and
we think it's going to start turning and
turning quickly and we believe we're
going to win in a with a nice uh nice
padding actually
so your opponent is the Secretary of
State
um
she didn't campaign much and she didn't
seem like she needed to campaign a lot
she never debated you and some are
smirking online that well of course she
was always confident uh in her Victory
what's your view of that very common
take on the race
you're trying to get me to say something
that might get me in trouble no no it's
just I've read 50 people say that
that that means people are so
distrustful what they're insinuating is
that she knew she could sit back hide in
the basement do nothing and win due to
cheating that's what they're insinuating
and I understand why they would
insinuate that because we've had such
terrible elections they're run poorly
they're ripe with fraud and we we've
seen this time and time again and
nothing's being done our elected
officials tell us if we dare bring it up
we are conspiracy theorists where
election deniers darn it we've got to
start bringing this up people are fed up
I was in a Veterans Day parade today and
people were shouting out from the side
of the road please repair our elections
please count our vote this is crazy the
people of Arizona are fed up and when we
win and rest assured we will with 100
certainty we will win one of the first
things I'm going to do on day one is
call a special session bring the
legislature in and say fix these
elections and restore honesty and
transparency so we can have faith in our
elections once again this is our sacred
vote we get one vote that's what we
should get one vote and we want to know
it counted
I'm not accusing your opponent of doing
anything wrong I have no knowledge of
that but she is the Secretary of State
and it seems that one of the main costs
of an election this chaotic is the
confidence of Voters that it's real so
why wouldn't she recuse herself for
appearance sake if no other before the
count began
we asked her to do that one month into
jumping into the race back in July of 21
we asked her to recuse herself we said
this is unethical it you know just
recuse yourself from the parts of your
role as Secretary of State that I deal
with the election and she refused to do
so but you know she only showed up for
work 19 days in the past six months so I
don't know how much work she does and we
had the big red flag on August 2nd the
primary election it played out exactly
like this they counted the Democrat
votes first they slow rolled the
Republican votes and it was days and
days and days of counting they did
nothing to improve it before this
general election and then we had the
tabulator machines that didn't work in a
third of the polling places we can't
continue to run elections this way we're
very confident Tucker that these
elections are going to start or these uh
these counts are going to start going
heavily our way and we will win this and
I assure the people of Arizona we will
clean up up our elections yeah and I my
viewers eliminate absentee ballots
except for you know the tiny percentage
who really need them this is this is
crazy and it really is hurting people's
view of democracy Carrie like I
appreciate your coming on tonight best
of luck thank you thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight